moi j'ai tendance à penser un peu comme
héraclite qu'il faut pas se baigner deux
fois dans le même fleuve que le temps
pour le parti socialiste ça reste mon
parti je paye encore ma cotisation même
si je ne peux pas dire bien sûr l'ami du
temps quotidien
ce parti doit est animé par des gens
jeunes qui ont envie de créer un nouvel
avenir qui à mon sens doute être social
démocrate c'est à dire vraiment de
gauche est vraiment européen
pour le socialiste français je crois
qu'il ya une place pour la social
démocratie car somme toute avec des
jeunes n'ont qu'un wii ait déjà l'ancien
président mais nous avons c'est ça
françois hollande et moi nous
appartenons aux instances du parti
socialiste nous avons en partie nos
agences de mardi sa liste pendant plus
de vingt ans donc c'est à d'autres de
faire et quand tu as un président la
république un ancien président de la
république comme françois hollande il
sera toujours une voix écoutée par les
français qu'il aime bien aussi
il sera toujours une voix écoutée par
son camp le camp qui l'a fait gagner
mais quand qui l'a aussi amené la
défaite et je crois qu'il faut qu'il
trouve son rôle et son rôle c'est de
trouver cette voie impartial cette voie
d'intérêt général cette voix forte le
doigt sur les questions internationales
européennes sans doute après oui mais
lille a plein de possibilités il est
encore jeune il peut faire plein de
choses je salue de choisir c'est donc
vous pour apprendre la suite au ps qui
selon vous pour les plusieurs jeunes qui
sont qui sont bien le droit de donner
des noms par exemple jeudi des jeunes
je ne met pas dedans et je pense qu'il
faut surtout aider les autres encore une
fois faut pas se remettre dans des rôles
qu'on a connu longtemps moi j'ai
appartenu aux instances du parti
socialiste pendant 20 ans je suis
toujours à socialiste je n'exclus pas de
refaire de la politique un jour mais je
ne le ferai pas comme un homme
d'appareil et il faut que cette jeunesse
s'empare des affaires du parti et je
vais ajouter une deuxième chose année
nous quelques noms quand même plus vous
l'avez vous les connaissez non justement
vous dire qu'elle aima martingale à moi
c'est que je leur suggère ils sont
plusieurs éditions des résidents n'ont
pas envie de chanter écouter souk dont
je lis les noms olivier faur boris
vallot mathias fait que najat vallaud
belkacem johanna rolland nathalie appéré
vous voilà des élus car vous d'un
souhait des jeunes d'hackers en 40 ans
ils ont plein de talent il n'y en a pas
un d'entre eux qui en à l'heure actuelle
et et je crois en situation d'être plus
leader du parti socialiste pour la suite
en tous cas de manière nette et claire
qui
entendent qu'il fasse équipe qu'ils
fassent pas qu il y en ait un qui dirige
le parti pour leur compte à tous et je
crois que ça marchera bien